[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my detroit players
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show live from our studio here in
kiev ukraine where we have moved the
show we followed joe rogan to the
ukraine which was stupid in hindsight
but in the beginning it sounded very
good because he said he was going to do
a comedy scene in eastern europe in uh
in cave which he said was what he did in
l.a and he said you could easily
replicate that in kiev
that was the pitch right that was the
idea he goes would you kill tony from
keeve and then you come
and then everybody will move to keeve
and it'll be fun that's what we thought
but egg on our faces because now we're
here and there's russians with tanks in
circling us
unfortunately
um
uh
we'll start with a war report up front
uh it's uh not good uh there but the
russians uh they underestimated the
ukrainians because the ukrainians are uh
they're tough people
and they're not easily uh occupiable and
they're not an easily occupied people
um
you know jesse signal herzog's uh
uh uh partner they do an unimportant
show at an uh at an unimportant place
but he had tweeted something to that
effect that uh it's gonna be a little
tougher to occupy these people than you
think they're not friendly over there
really right
uh they're they're just blowing up these
tanks and putin's just trying to help
these people and get the nazis out of
the country and they're angry at this
and it's weird they don't even like see
the bigger picture they're running
around they're attacking russian
soldiers they're blowing up troops
it's crazy because uh putin's saying
we're there's nazis over there and we're
just trying to get rid of them because
we don't like the nazis
and
uh the ukrainian people are you know
everybody thought you know putin and
myself and others were like when he goes
in there they're gonna go thank god
someone noticed these uh nazis here
let's uh uh get rid of them you know and
speaking from america a country with no
nazis ever never
no we had nothing to do with building
the third reich we had nothing to do
with uh co-mingling our financial
systems with hitler
at all at all don't even think it uh and
we we are just we hate uh nazism in
america we hate fascism we hate it
that's why we do the military flyovers
at the football games because fascism to
us is like no good
um but they do have some nazis now
obviously i'm being a little facetious
google it but they do have some nazis
over there in that azoff battalion which
um
uh is not good because they're doing the
sikh heiling
and they're into the they're they like
uh the azov battalion and so facebook is
now allowing praise of neo-nazi
ukrainian battalion if it fights russian
invasion this is like the patrice
o'neill bit you have sexual harassment
day facebook's just gotta reserve a day
for everyone to praise the nazi of their
choice
whether it's liaison battalion or
someone in america you should have a day
to praise the nazi of your choice on
facebook there should be one day just
like patrice said about sexual
harassment you would go in you go i can
harass you today i think you should be
able to praise the nazi on facebook for
one day out of the year i think it's
fair and it shouldn't only have to be
the azo battalion it could be your
neighbor who showed you some weird cool
world war ii
uh paraphernalia that he's got and he's
you know you could say hey man my
neighbor chucks is a nazi and today's
his day i respect the hell out of him he
takes in my mail when i'm gone but he's
literally a nazi not all of his ideas
are great clearly but he's kind of a
cool dude i think that's good facebook's
now allowing us for people to just call
for violence against ukrainian against
russians
facebook's allowing people to just
basically the social media company is
temporarily allowing some posts to call
for death to russian president vladimir
putin or belarusian president alexander
lukashenko well that's not right
according to internal emails and content
moderators they're basically saying let
them have it
let them have it as a result of the
russian invasion of ukraine we have
temporarily made allowances for forms of
political expression that would normally
violate our rules like violent speech
such as death to russian invaders
we still won't allow credible calls for
violence against russian civilians now
who decides what's credible and what's
not there's a large chunk of russians
living in the ukraine
so by allowing this type of stuff you
might be fomenting some type of
civil war which is not what mark
zuckerberg intended he just wanted to
get his dick wet he wanted a cool
exclusive and by the way could anything
be less exclusive than facebook but
that's how you make billions of dollars
right you give up the exclusivity you
let everybody in you started out you're
like i just want hot singles that are
going places that can communicate with
each other and then later on you're
fomenting a civil war in the ukraine and
you don't even know how it happens but
it just does what a life
now citing the reuters story russia's
embassy in the u.s demanded that
washington stop the quote extremist
activities of meta
the temporary policy changes on calls
for violence to russian soldiers applied
to armenia azerbaijan estonia georgia
okay i feel like i'm reading an ad
the promo code is not applicable in
armenia azerbaijan estonia georgia
hungary latvia lithuania poland romania
russia slovakia and ukraine
except for dunbas
um
and so now the white house because
there's there's this propaganda in the
war everybody's uh has their take on
things right there's people in america
that think that uh we have of course two
groups of very rational people here
people that believe that putin is cool
because he's restoring uh the greatness
to the white christian nation of russia
which again historically has been
incredibly godless
but
uh putin who's devoutly religious now
uh who was a soviet his entire life but
but you know a godless soviet but some
people believe that it's cool because we
are the godless west and there's there's
uh drag queens are reading the cat in a
hat and we got all kinds of problems
here and putin's a strong man and he's
not woke
that's some people they go we like him
who cares that no one there has any
money and they die at 60. it doesn't
matter they're not woke
and then we have the other people the
other the other half of that again we
have the people that are like he's great
this is great uh the deaths of uh women
children men everybody uh elderly people
the displacement of people it's all cool
and it's all justified uh because you
know
they don't have to sit through
oscar's speeches that bring up politics
you know because he's
not woke so this is it's ultimately not
woke right to invade a country it's like
the least woke thing you could do i
guess is to uh
invade with tanks
uh and then the other group of people we
have here again very rational just go we
just need a nuclear war
to show the support like we need a
no-fly zone which brings us into direct
conflict with putin and those people are
going okay
maybe we'll do a 10-year civil war where
we arm the ukraine not fight
with them or for them but we arm them
with our weapons that they buy
and we uh arm them and we just create
syria in eastern europe you know
and then there's people that go that's
not good enough we need nukes we need we
need to to do a real nuclear exchange
here we need to push putin and see how
far he can go isolate him sanction him
put him put his back to the wall and
let's see if he'll really push the
button we got some sick [ __ ] here so
those are the two crews we have putin's
awesome
uh this is great we love this thank god
for this
and then the other side of the people
that go hey let's have a nuclear war to
to show our support for the ukraine
nothing shows our support more uh than a
nuclear exchange both of those uh aren't
uh uh
helpful
and uh i was gonna talk about this too
the white house is briefing tick tock
stars about the war in ukraine with
millions getting their information about
the war from tick tock the
administration wants to get its message
to the top content creators this is what
i talked about whatever you think of
what russia did here whether you think
it was justified by uh the expansion of
nato uh with slavoshi had a good point
he's like this this this whole idea is
like yes some of that led to it but like
this whole idea that countries should
have like a sphere of influence isn't
like any type of principled leftism or
whatever not that this is a leftist show
but it may be today it started out as a
nazi show and it may be left to show and
then by the end it's a nazi show again
to cover all the internet and then the
beginning we give you a little
neoliberal uh sushi
in the in the in the in the middle just
a little like fun dating taps and then
we we we oscillate between fascists and
uh communists
but
uh so the tic tacs because here's what's
happening in ukraine and people don't
understand it nothing
it's not conventional war is boring no
one no one cares it held our attention
for 72 hours at most couple of missiles
you see the tank you got the cell phone
video and then the people all the
refugees are running and the ratty
little sweaters it said we hate it no
good but after a while it gets a little
like okay it's taxing what do you really
want me to do
well i've been there done that we get it
it's it's it's dated it's retro war is
retro it's dated frankly it's not
exciting
in the sense that you know the images
that are coming out of there it's very
european it's very world war ii
it's very period piece even the clothes
they're wearing nothing's new nothing's
modern so i'm not really connected to
you i'm not connecting to it i'm not
connecting to it i'm like okay yeah i
get it what you're doing and i
understand the tanks and the weapons and
the stainers and the but it just feels
more like a world war ii film that i
didn't see
and someone said i should have but i
didn't and that's the problem because
there is no con putin does not have a
content strategy
he's got some of the alt-right on his
side in america and we've got some uh
you know what i mean he's got a few
people but he doesn't really have a
content strategy now one thing you could
say about america we don't educate our
people they die on the streets uh we
don't give them retirement we let
billionaires uh pillage us and then we
worship them uh we do a lot of horrible
things we have a massive chaos in the
city we have a crime problem that is uh
uh it makes a third world country murder
numbers look good
uh we have organized gangs we have
militias storming our government
buildings we have uh congressman insider
trading selling stocks we have an insane
amount of corruption we have a nexus of
uh national security agencies that are
in bed
with business people and private defense
contractors inching us closer to nuclear
war every single minute however we do
content baby we make content as gary v
says we don't slack off on the content
and if you do you'll see it in your
numbers
and that's what we're seeing here with
putin is that he went in there with
tanks and missiles thinking it was going
to matter but it doesn't because he
doesn't have a content strategy the
physical world doesn't matter nearly as
much as the digital world i've been
saying this on joe rogan i've been
ringing this bell and no one listens to
me
i can't get anything going on the net
people have a trump on i'm getting
dodged by tulsi gabbard
i can't even get tulsi gabbard and
darren mar-a-lago with trump i can't
even get uh tulsi gabbard here and i
promised her uh caviar and russian vodka
and she won't come in
i sent that to her i said you come in
here and do whatever pro-red thing you
want i don't care we do a whole thing
for you we bring her in give her caviar
a little russian vodka and we played a
soviet national anthem on repeat
now
i don't think she's a russian asset but
it's just funny to imagine that she is
it's funny to think that she is and i
hope she is because good for her you
gotta do so hey a career in this
business ain't easy okay i've been doing
it a long time and whether she's a
russian asset or not she's out there
making content
now
because uh so
jen saki who's an idiot by the way she's
an idiot she's a ginger everything about
her is wrong uh i don't know why we we
why don't they have a black woman doing
press secretary that delivers like
fun like
you better recognize like why not that
why don't we have like a fun black woman
who's like you better ask somebody like
quick off the cuff just burn you like
only a black woman could do but we got
this pale white [ __ ] she's like wow
actually in america
fun black woman is press secretary
that's what i think
thursday afternoon 30 tick tock stars
top tick tock stars gathered on a zoom
call to receive key information about
the war unfolding in ukraine national
security council staffers in white house
press secretary chen saki briefed the
influencers about the united states
strategic goals in the region and
answered questions i mean can you
imagine
can you imagine by the way the questions
like they're answering questions can you
imagine like um yeah
yeah can
what's like
what's what are they like yeah
what are they where are they like big
are they like are they like big on insta
or are they like
what are they what are they doing
who like are they sponsored
do you have a
brand yell
with morph when morph kicked off james
charles did they did they deal with the
ukraine
is the ukraine a cosmetics company
is the ukrainian company that will
sponsor me
i mean can you imagine these uh people
and their questions because they're
answering questions by the way can
there's got to be something that jen
sakes is more important in her day than
answering the questions of 15 year old
brain dead tick tick-tock idiots there's
got to be something going on but
probably not um
so they just wanted to brief the
influencers about the united states
strategic goals in the region and
answered questions about distributing
aid to ukrainians
so like
from what i understand like this is
about pipelines and ports and like
jen saki had a zoom call with us and she
told us about like
she went into like a lot of really cool
stuff about like spheres of influence
and like i have a sphere of influence
too
and that's like what i've always said
and it's just because when i started
making content i was four
and my parents really helped me
but then like by the time i was 12 i was
like literally one of the biggest people
on the platform
and my sphere of influence is huge
because like i helped so many other
young creators and their journeys and
like i don't even talk about it because
it's not important
the white house has been closely
watching tick tocks rise as a dominant
news source leading to its decision to
approach a select group of platform's
most influential names can we get the
who they were do we know who they are
yeah so they list them throughout this
article so this is the first guy
khalil green khalil greene okay are they
i mean
but some of these guys have like 500 000
followers they don't have [ __ ] the real
tick tockers are out here in la these
are the people you need getting involved
you need the demilio sisters you don't
need people doing news on tick-tock
you need to find these uh teenagers and
people in their early 20s shaking their
ass you got to get them talking about
the ukraine you got to get tana mojo
doing ukraine on tits
this doesn't help anybody
the briefing was led by matt miller a
special adviser for communications at
the white house national security
council and sake um
the washington post obtained a recording
of the call in it biden officials trust
the power of these creators quote we
recognize this is a critically important
avenue in the way the american public is
finding out about the latest
said rob flaherty so we wanted to make
sure you had the latest information from
an authoritarian
authoritative source
um
see this is the game here with the
misinformation everybody's got to stop
with the you know this is the new thing
now
um they worked with dozens of top tick
tock stars last year to encourage the
vaccination so this is what's happening
so now whether you agree with the
vaccination uh what you're seeing is the
white house is co-opting
our greatest minds
and using them against us
uh the white house is going to tick-tock
and using our greatest
minds and polluting them with propaganda
now whether that propaganda is
good bad indifferent whether it's
warranted or not
uh this is what the white house is doing
they are trying to
co-opt tick-tock
and this is something we should
watch this is important people don't
think it's about but this is the content
strategy that putin lacks where you know
some of these russian tick tock stars
should also be he should be having a
call with the russian tick tocks can you
imagine explaining that to putin going i
know you come from like another era
listen to me can you sit down for a
minute
i understand all of that i understand
your concerns about the convoy but
here's really what it is
we need you to call into red scare
red skit
do you watch
succession do you what listen
it's the missiles it's irrelevant i'm
asking you right now are you unfamiliar
with red scare or are you just
pretending to be unfamiliar with it
listen you need to call in there and get
your point of view across
okay
yeah they're like from here red scare
they like one of them's families like
from there
so like
now and by the way i want to speak about
these oligarchs too for a little bit
because this is very troubling to me
i want you to google alisher uzmanov
these people are being treated like uh
like like second-class citizens look at
this man this is a man after my own
heart look at this man
okay
this guy and get his yacht up
he looks like stavros a little this
guy's this guy's yuck look at this man's
yacht look at this yacht
look at this
dill bar the world's largest motor yacht
is owned by alastair um they are making
these people flee on these yachts
italy has taken
two of them i believe two of these
yachts
and they are uh
you know what's the term here they're
impounding them or they're i guess
confiscating them
i would say and pounding them they're uh
they haven't really like uh
like arrested anybody or anything but
like they've just they just taken two
years ago here are the mega yachts
belonging to russian oligarchs let's go
through that oh no it's business insider
i don't even want to get well i don't
like them but they wanted to run a hit
piece on me and they didn't oh right
they didn't
but because the guy ended up quitting
but um italy sees this russian
oligarch's 530 million dollar mega yacht
we're talking euros but
i mean let's talk about this here
because i don't know that i'm for this
i'm a big fan of the mega yacht the
problem with the mini yacht is there's
never enough outdoor space
you do you have you've seen these yachts
because a lot of the yachts what you do
is it's it's so luxurious inside but
there's not a ton of outdoor space and
when you are boating you want a lot of
sun and you want a lot of space and with
a lot of the yachts and you could spend
80 90 million on a boat and you still
don't get the outdoor space you need
what's great about a mega yacht is is
the proportion
the proportions of the boat you do get
more outdoor space italy's financial
police seized a 530 million dollar super
yacht belonging to russian oligarch
andre igorovich melinchenko
a spokesperson for the italian
government said today the vessel was
seized on friday in the northeastern
port of trieste
uh among the world's largest he's one of
the oligarchs subject to sanctions
following russia's invasion of ukraine
according to the eu he quote belongs to
the most influential circle of russian
business people with close connections
to the russian government as such he is
in quote an economic sectors providing a
substantial source of revenue to the
government of the but they're not taking
these yachts to the ukraine and using
them to launch attacks
these are not boats designed for war
they're boats designed for pleasure
so my question is this is clearly not
military artillery
are we just doing this to make their
lives difficult
alisher uzmanov he said he was quoted he
goes i'm not even what you'd call an
oligarch get that up
he goes i don't even know what this is
he goes i i i'm like confused here
i mean this is great i mean this is uh
here right here
what does he say right here right here
yeah
never
he goes
he goes listen i was never what you
could call an oligarch
the russian billionaire worked with
putin his premier league plants are
making a fortune in the 90s
and this is from january so this guy and
this wasn't even during the war right
you know but he's like hey man he's got
like 17 million he's like i don't even
know what this is about bro
like
i love this guy get it get it
let's get another image of him yeah he's
great he's phenomenal and
what is my beef like i don't know that i
have a beef with him
and i don't know that we
have to take his yacht
i mean
this is a gu i
is there a person out there that i'm
gonna get along with better than this
guy
this is the problem with politics is
there someone
that i would have a better time at a
dinner with than this man
the answer is no
this guy or zilinski at a dinner
no brainer no
brainer they're freezing the guy's
assets he's probably got a little on the
side i hope
god i hope he's got a little on the side
he has assets frozen by eu over ties to
putin
it's it's just unfortunate
i love raycon earpods i've switched to
them and i wear them every day raycon
you know the way i feel about raycon
earbuds i love them i think you should
buy them you should have them as your
main pair a backup pair get them for
your friends and family they are cheaper
than the other big headphones but they
are better they've got over six hours of
play time it's amazing there are so many
different settings with raycon earbuds
so you can you know you you can put them
on awareness mode where if you're
jogging basically you could still be
aware of your surroundings i'm telling
you it's great raycon is the move
switched to raycon because they are less
expensive and they work better than the
other name brand earbuds that you hear
about all the time they've got eight
hours of play time 32 hour battery life
they're priced just right you get great
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday ear buds have over 48
000 five-star reviews right now
tim dillon show listeners can get 15 off
their raycon order at byraycon.com
tim that's by raycon.com
tim to save 15 on ray cons buy
raycon.com
tim you will never look better than with
uh some raycon wireless earbuds in your
ears fact what's the first thing you put
on every morning if you answered my
existential dread then we have some
friends who can help with that
but the second thing we're talking about
underwear right me undies believes you
have the right to be comfortable and if
you are comfortable you can do anything
that includes having a positive outlook
on your day while wearing fun and
ridiculous prints on your butt everyone
loves me undies they make the softest
fabrics you've ever put on your body so
you can sit on your couch all day or go
out and live your comfiest life try
their me undies socks
bralettes loungewear you'll never go
back choose from a range of limited
edition prints and colors from extra
small to 4xl you can sign up for their
free to join me on these memberships
where you get a monthly subscription
that sends new styles right to your door
which is a lot of fun uh i'm telling you
me undies are great they are it's a
great if you need underwear and you love
our show and you want to support us this
is some of the best underwear on the
market maybe the best it is so soft they
have a great offer for my listeners for
any first first-time purchasers you get
15 off and free shipping
15 off and free shipping me undies also
has their promise if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason you can return your order for a
full refund within 45 days to get your
15 off your first order and free
shipping go to meundies.com tim tim
that's meundies.com
tim tim they are so comfortable you're
going to love them the subscription is
great because you get new ones all the
time you don't have to go out and buy
underwear they just show right up
they've got fun prints i mean what do
you want i mean we both wear them we
both use this product we're wearing them
right now everybody's wearing them
what is that it says
oh is that really what it is yeah i
think so yeah it's an otter they sent me
one with an otter on it
interesting
otters there's a whole thing that they
rape baby seals
no it's true michelle wolf i think had a
bit about it where it's like people
think otters are like nice animals but
they it's a whole thing i think it was
michelle wolf i don't know
what happened to her
anyway she's around i guess
um
what are we talking about here maybe
i mean
are they not the best
all right go away
by the way so zielinski right now he
keeps calling for the no-fly zone
calling for jets he's calling for things
that you go hey man we can't do any of
this and he still just won't stop and
we support ukraine they should be able
to determine their own future or a
sovereign country and i think the
invasion is monstrous but i also believe
that like
you can't keep asking for a world war
three
you gotta take a deal here buddy take a
deal of course you're not gonna like to
deal
but that's okay take a deal
and by the way i want you to get up
something right now because everybody's
like oh what do we do what do we do
i want you to have a word document right
now because i believe in the power of
the sternly worded letter i've always
believed that
think of when you were coming home you
know when a teacher tucked a letter in
your
pocket or your backpack that had to go
to your mother how terrified were you on
the bus
you were terrified and then you got home
maybe you were a latchkey kid and you
got to uh it's like going home with the
report card when there is a note that
you know your mother has to read from
the teacher and you can't even open it
you don't know what it really says and
sometimes you know what it says because
you watch the teacher write it and
you're like if i don't give it to my
mother i'm more than [ __ ] because the
teacher's gonna call cause the teacher
will tell you i'm calling to make sure
she read it dear vladimir putin
right now cause enough's enough dear
vladimir putin
hey buddy
now what hey buddy does is right off the
bat he's wondering is this are they is
am i really his buddy because when
someone says hey buddy it's kind of
aggressive do you know what i mean sure
like your brother says it nice he was
like hey buddy but a lot of people don't
uh hey buddy it's kind of like it's kind
of like a kind of an aggro move right so
you go hey buddy so right off the bat
right off the bat he's on the defensive
hey buddy next line okay
the war in ukraine you don't do that ben
you indent oh don't you know how to ride
well we already did deer so then we did
we do another indent i guess yeah well
because hey buddy is its own thing okay
okay
hey buddy
the war in ukraine
is
ridiculous
okay
this is not your best moment
in fact
it's literally one of your worst
it's not so much the bombing
or the shelling ben can you fix it sorry
it's not so much the bombing
or the shelling
of civilian of heavily civilian areas
if anyone understands that we do lol
because you want to you want to you want
to also like build rapport
if anyone understands that we do lol
the reality is
that this is now [ __ ]
with everybody's money
and we know that was never your goal
but
that is what is happening
so
please cut it out
before we're all broke
and no one has enough money to kill
signed
barry weiss
simon barry weiss
read it back
dear vladimir putin
hey buddy
the war in ukraine is ridiculous this is
not your best moment
in fact it's literally one of your worst
it's not so much the bombing or the
shelling of heavily civilian areas if
anyone understands that we do lol
the reality is
that this is now [ __ ] with
everybody's money and we know that was
never your goal but that is what is
happening
so please cut it out before we are all
broke and no one has enough money to
kill
signed barry wise
you're telling me that has no effect i
doubt it
you're telling me that has no effect if
it goes over there and he realizes what
he's doing he's [ __ ] with everybody's
money
we're all trying to build death machines
here
we're all trying to do it
we're all trying to run ponzi schemes in
the financial sector we're all trying to
build uh sick people for insulin money
we're all trying to [ __ ] over the poor
and and we're all trying to do this and
this guy's getting in the way now
because it's [ __ ] our money up with
the gas prices high how are we gonna
drive all the kids to the private
prisons
you know how much it costs now to drive
a group of kids to a private prison
you know the cost of everything's gonna
go up not just gas plastics metals
the restraints that we put those kids in
ain't cheap
the materials to make the restraints
that we put our children in when we ship
them to a private prison
are not free
so this is [ __ ] everybody's money up
when we
fly some mission
to go bomb someone is that gas on the
house no
okay
when the police are doing ride-alongs in
different neighborhoods looking for
people to kill
they have to have gas as well
do you understand that
are you not with that or something wrong
with you
okay
when a realtor drives a young couple
around so she can trick them into buying
a house they can't afford
and they take out a mortgage that they
can't pay back and they spend the next
10 or 20 years of their life mired in
hopeless depression and addictions to
just drag themselves out of bed to go to
the jobs they hate to spend the money to
pay that mortgage while their children
are literally masturbating on only fans
for money
who puts the gas in the car to get that
going
so what i'd like you to do
mr vladimir putin is realize
how hard it is for everybody
to participate in the society that we've
set up here
with a high price of fuel
it's unfortunate i want to read about
this thing a guy got fired for reading a
book about butts really yes he read a
book about butts to a couple of second
graders and they fired him it's in the
new york times which i god i hope you're
subscribed to him or you're getting hit
no i i did it all
uh
did you subscribe to the cleveland plain
dealer that one i did
that one i did not
the cleveland played it's a real paper
when i go when i do hilarities and i eat
at slimens where they get you a corned
beef sandwich at 8 a.m
and then they have the cleveland plain
dealer there you could get corned beef
ash or you could get a reuben and they
they give you the cleveland playing
dealer there's a great um
photo on my instagram of pancakes and
slime
on the cleveland plain dealer toby price
an assistant principal at an elementary
school in mississippi
read a book called i need a new butt to
children
uh read the book to a glass of second
graders over zoom i'm a firm believer
that reluctant readers need the silly
funny books to hook them in and they
fired this guy this is what i mean
things are starting to get crazy okay
it was read across america week and the
second graders in the heinz hins heinz
who cares school district in mississippi
that's underfunded we're waiting for an
administrator to read to them the
administrator has forgotten it was her
turn said toby price the assistant
principal at gary road elementary school
in hinds county who was in his office at
the time he decided to fill in so mr
price 46 quickly grabbed the book quote
i need a new bot by dawn mcmillan one of
his children's favorites and began
reading it to the roughly 242nd graders
over zoom later that day on march 2nd
the district superintendent
martin called him in your office and
told him he was on administrative leave
mr price said he was fired two days
later accused of violating the standards
of conduct section of the mississippi
educator code now they probably think
it's a trans book in mississippi what do
you mean you need new butt you got the
butt that god gave you trans people
aren't even getting new bots
but
she said the book was inappropriate the
superintendent called the book
inappropriate she particularly took
issue with the references to farting
in the story and how quote the book
described butts in various colors shapes
and sizes example fireproof bulletproof
bomb proof
and miss martin called mr price
unprofessional for having selected the
book
this guy's been an educator for 20 years
he has hired a lawyer and he's going to
fight this but this is how crazy it's
getting out there
this is a little wacky can you get this
book up i need a new butt and let's see
how bad this is maybe i'm wrong this is
one of those things where i could have
an egg on my face when we get to page
three in a book and we realize it is
crazy
i need a new butt
a young boy suddenly notices he has a
big problem his butt has a huge crack
so he sets off to find a new one so
here's the it's a silly book
this isn't a young boy uh finds out he
has a big problem that he doesn't want
his [ __ ] anymore it's that his butt is a
crack which all butts do that's the bit
um will you choose an armor-plated butt
a rocket butt a robot butt find out in
this quirky tail of a uh quirky
tail of a tail get it yeah yeah yeah
which features hilarious rhymes and
delightful illustrate is there any way
we can read a little bit is there a
preview here let's preview it okay so
here's the uh so this is the book that
this guy was fired
for reading to the kids which i don't
understand okay i need a new bot
by
don mcmillan illustrated by russ
kinnaird okay
again there's a a a boy he's looking his
butt and there he goes uh in the uh
mirror
i need a new butt
mine's got a crack in it
the cia put crack in black communities
in the 80s and then denied
responsibility for it
okay well
[Music]
this now is
a little different than what i was led
to believe i
i thought this was mainly a fun book
about butt cracks
all right let's go to page two i'm sure
it gets better okay
did i do it on a slide
he's going down a water slide
uh where he got the crack in his butt
right yeah yeah or on the banister
inside
or when i jump my bmx
or with the fart that happened next
of course the fart that's what blew my
butt apart split the thing clean in two
now i wonder what to do i don't really
trust the jews this is not see this is
the problem
they sneak in
they sneak in these little things
i need a new one a green one or a blue
one but not a brown one see i don't
again
obviously i'm
being silly and stupid this is a fine
book and can you believe this guy got
fired for this
he was fired
for reading a dumb silly book
because he wanted the kids to be
interested in it he goes listen you
can't read them war and peace
mcdonald's ice cream woes have inspired
memes we've done that already
that just caught my eye they're bringing
this back i guess
i just you know
see the whole thing is mcdonald's a
malfunctioning ice cream machine but we
all know what it is
um
they they have to clean it it takes a
long time to clean i mean supposedly but
that that's the party line
that's the the company story here
but we don't know if that's true or not
oh that company's suing mcdonald's now
okay what which company that makes the
uh makes the um
the uh ice cream
why are they suing they're saying you
can stop lying to people uh it's
accusing the chain of working with the
taylor company the manufacturer of its
ice cream machines to libel quiche while
simultaneously trying to copy its
technology
huh you can't trust mcdonald's
we're hearing about crypto everywhere
crypto companies are investing in stars
like tom brady and lebron james they
even dominated the super bowl ad
spending in millions to get in front of
sports fans but some of these companies
had their website crash on the big day
or have poorly rated customer service
meanwhile exodus is investing in making
e making easy to use crypto apps and has
built a world-class customer support
team and if you don't even have to
submit your personal details like your
mom's maiden name to use it just
download exodus and you're all set did
you hear about canada authorizing
financial institutions to freeze
people's accounts who are suspected of
supporting those protesting vaccine
mandates they don't even have to prove
that you're doing it if your money or
crypto is being held by a banker
exchange it's not really yours if you
can't spend it how you want it's not
yours get your money under your control
by holding it in a crypto wallet like
exodus no sign up required and your
funds cannot be
frozen that's huge inflation is insane
right now things are getting more
expensive wages aren't going up and the
government keeps printing money to give
away to people who already have a lot of
money the traditional financial system
is sinking and bitcoin is a life raft
it's time to ditch your bank leave
traditional finance behind and join the
financial revolution exodus is a crypto
app for your phone and computer that is
easy to use supports 150 crypto assets
looks great and has world-class customer
support over 150 crypto assets we're
hearing a lot about this right now it is
important to put your crypto in a wallet
where they cannot freeze it are you
confused by crypto exodus makes it easy
for you to get started in minutes an app
that is easy to use so even your grandma
can use it are your friends and family
or maybe even your favorite music artist
investing in crypto and you feel left
out exodus can help you get started
quickly carry your wallet everywhere in
the world in exchange over 150 assets in
two taps
i mean it's great it's easy
exchange stake or store your crypto
whatever your goal is exodus will make
it easier and beautiful to do manage and
exchange over 150 crypto assets straight
from your phone or computer i'm using
this now and i love it oh and you use it
we're all starting to use it over four
million people trust exodus to manage
your crypto join the movement away from
traditional finance by downloading
exodus go to exodus.com tim to get
started it's a great way to support our
show and this is really something that
can get you into crypto if you're novice
or if you're not a novice it's a great
way to really securely store your crypto
it's time to take control of your wealth
get started by downloading exodus on
mobile
and desktop at exodus.com tim exodus is
a crypto wallet for everyone no sign up
is required download and you're ready to
go by visiting exodus.com
tim
so many people are struggling with their
mental health right now and you know why
you know why because life's tough but
betterhelp.com is here better help
better b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com tim d
that's where you're gonna get a deal
what better help is is this great
online counseling service it is great
because some types of counseling are not
available
physically where you are
better help you do everything online if
you don't like your counselor you can
change your counselor you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it is
very very important that you keep track
of your mental health it's going to
allow you to do everything in life that
you want over 2 million people have used
better help online therapy it's an
online therapy service that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
folks the choice is really yours it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try
i'm telling you it's a great way
to safeguard uh and improve upon your
mental health the podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp and tim dillon show
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com tim d tim dylan show
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com timday this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp online therapy
ron desantis by the way is at a war with
disney over the don't say gay bill
because he said disney's woke and
don't say gay bill by the way that i
have a funny bid on it now on stage but
from what i looked into it's just you
can't instruct the kids on gender theory
before they're three or something
kindergarten to second grade yeah who
disagrees with that really who needs
what are we doing and there already
wasn't a curriculum in place uh in that
state yeah so it's like don't bring in a
new curriculum to teach people to teach
uh
seven-year-olds about gender they just
doesn't need to happen right
it doesn't need to happen nobody thinks
it needs to happen
um
but this really gets to the heart of the
uh problem where
uh there is this argument uh that i
would be very sympathetic to that a lot
of kids when they are young that
experience
uh some type of gender dysphoria if it's
not major gender dysphoria a lot of them
will end up just kind of being gay
perhaps they will not feel the need to
physically alter themselves some will
some are probably genuinely 100 trans
but if a six-year-old wears a dress they
could be experimenting they're having
fun maybe they end up being gay it may
not be
uh
something that is really indicative of
how they want to live the rest of their
life i think that's a pretty rational
sane position i don't think it's a crazy
turf insane position which again is
you know another word that we've made up
to just you know if you recognize any
biological difference between a man and
a woman you're a turf and again
the vast majority of people do recognize
those differences and that isn't at all
a rejection of trans identity or or
trying to hurt trans people now there
are some people that make it their
entire brand they speak about nothing
except the differences between men and
women which is you know it's maybe a
little suspect a little sauce where it's
like the only thing you talk about over
and over again and they do it on both
sides well where are the trans people in
the ukraine gonna go and it's just every
single minute is trans trans transgender
are there de-transitioners in the
ukraine what about them what about the
people who cut their tits off with
ukraine and what that it's back and you
go why is this every day all day every
minute every minute
every second of the day we're doing this
over and over again because i guess it's
just this is some people's beat
and i understand and there's people that
have written uh really interesting stuff
about it
and i understand that and it it it does
seem to be more and more of the culture
it's more and more of an issue people
are fighting about it more and more and
it's i'm a very who cares person on this
because uh number one i don't have
children number two
if i had children um i would
you know i would not want them altering
their bodies until they were old enough
really to fully make that conscious
choice and i've said that before i don't
think that's a a a a trans
um
exclusionary point of view now are there
parents that would disagree with me and
go no my child
genuinely feels that going through
puberty would be abuse
and they and and and because they are
super trans there should be a council to
just decide if your kid's really trans
like there should be a like a council of
people that go like you are legit there
are some kids that are trained if
there's like a four-year-old with like a
beard and she's like yup bro what up i'm
like all right just let her not have the
tits but a lot of them you feel like
they're just experimenting you know i
could have been trans when i was young
like i i was i had like very like
feminine uh qualities you know a lot of
people do i still do most men i know
have feminine qualities now like and
they have sex with women so
this idea that reducing everything to
this very
simplistic understanding of everything i
just i just i get a little worried when
the pharmaceutical companies get in bed
with everybody and they go they need
these and that and hormones and the
pills and some kids do some kids are
genuinely trans and there needs to be a
way to decide that like why isn't jk
rowling instead of just again with the
man woman man woman
do a new harry potter book about a
council of people who decides which
wizards are trans or not when they're
children
you know that hat
where you go to gryffindor or slytherin
because the sorting hat knows you better
than you know you well this we need a
sorting hat for trans kids to find out
who's really in and who's out because
you can't get well you can't get to tits
back right you could get implants can't
you just get it back anyway
can't you just explain to the kids if if
you don't want titties but you might get
the titties
later but then the problem is you take
all the hormones and you're like
but i think if the top stop taking them
it'll wear off too but i don't know
maybe these uh hormones and pills aren't
nearly as effective as i think they are
uh yeah you got you have to keep taking
them you have to it's it's a regimen
you're a kid
and you you you transition kind of
but i guess that does [ __ ] up your body
if you don't go through natural puberty
for sure yeah probably because yeah
that's right but my whole thing is this
like
i'm i'm almost a fan of the take a tit
leave a tit model you ever see the take
a book leave a book
it's our last episode but do you ever
see what i mean here take a book leave a
book where uh usually like crazy old
librarian witch women
will put out a bowl of books like
outside of their homes or
outside of some place of business or
something and there'll be a take a book
leave a book and the the idea there is
that you take a book and replenish it
with a book that maybe you finished to
promote reading in the community i'm
almost a fan of the take a tit leave a
tit where
could can we make it easier and cheaper
for people to just get tits whenever
they want or take tits away
because the problem is how expensive
this all is isn't that the issue here
isn't it expensive because
you can't just walk in there and get uh
the poon made into a peen it's a little
bit of dough mark norman had a great
joke he's like you call a lot of these
people brave caitlyn jenner's brave
she's just rich
it was mark norman joke it's a brilliant
joke where it was like
it's not
some people just don't have that ability
is my point
because insurance doesn't cover these
procedures often right for sure but my
thing is it gets messy when it's kids
because kids don't know what they're
doing
you know they don't know the kids don't
really know and they might regret it
some of them might regret it some of
them do regret it right there's all
these d transitioners
katie herzog's written 15 novels about d
transitioners and they've been
translated into many different languages
she wrote a war and peace style novel in
russian about the transitioners
it was war and peace but what if
everyone had de-transitioned they were
trans and they went back
um
so that's my whole thing on this i think
kids need to be kids i think adults need
to leave kids alone we have a weird
society now where adults are all over
children and telling them what to do and
who to be and how to believe i think
children need to figure out who they are
i think
kids are going to figure out if they're
gay if they're trans they need to figure
that out with their with their own i
don't think that we need to
impose
a value system
on children
uh
that are too young to completely
understand what decisions they're making
i've said it a million times i'm just
wondering if there's a happy medium i'll
take it to leave a ted
is there a happy me what about instead
of the operation let them dress
what about realistic prosthetics here we
go
give him a [ __ ]
that's like a like a fake [ __ ] oh
right like mr potato header like yes
instead of doing anything medical
give them
jelly tits and or a fake [ __ ] or
something no i'm dead serious it's funny
because you can laugh at it but instead
of doing something that's irreversible
why don't you give them
like a more realistic
bot like a suit to wear
is that not a good idea like oh you
think you're a dude here's a fake [ __ ]
now in a few years you might want a real
[ __ ] or you might take this off and go i
don't want the fake [ __ ] anymore
it's not a bad idea has anyone pitched
this probably but it's a happy medium
right
it if your son wants to be a chick
instead of doing something irreversible
medically
do like a missed out fire every morning
where you make him into the woman he
wants to be
if you had a son it'd kind of be i mean
listen unless you're really homophobic
and i'm sure not every dad would be
thrilled about not every dad would be
thrilled about
making your son doing your son drag
every morning
but it could be fun
you buy them little um
the leopard coat and uh you know you
don't want to make it buffoonish but
they shouldn't be without style
now
is that a happy medium
now like and and and then dad might not
like it as the dad's putting the wig on
and doing the makeup
and then the mom might go
listen you think this is you don't like
this well the other option is something
irreversible medical that we can't
afford and the dad goes i guess you're
right
and he adjusts the wig and he puts the
lipstick i mean literally who cares
i'm one of the the most progressive
people when it comes to gender because i
don't care men women hermaphrodite i
i've had friends that i consider
hermaphrodites even though they're not i
have friends where like i i know women
with like beards i've i've been friends
with like women with beards me and the
honestly used to talk about like italian
women in long island are all kind of
trans they're like
they're all very masculine like this
whole idea of this gender is this rigid
thing i do find antiquated and outdated
so i'm just wondering if there's a happy
medium or if there is not a happy medium
i don't
i don't really know anyway let's plug
some of these dates because this is the
end of the tour it's the end of the road
and then i'm transitioning to someone
who's not on the road
bray improv on sunday come out
california in the mall at brea we're
having fun wednesday march 16th some
tickets available for toronto march 18th
baltimore maryland march saturday march
19th philadelphia pennsylvania thursday
march 24th nashville tennessee saturday
march 26th denver special taping early
show late show wednesday march 30th
glasgow scotland saturday april said go
to scotland buy those tickets we're not
doing great over there please
uh april saturday april dublin early and
late shows in ireland then monday april
4th to uk
wednesday april 4th the uk
uh i'm sorry monday wednesday april 6 uk
april 6 late show in the uk
here are some new dates thursday
jacksonville florida at the florida
theater friday april 15th charlotte
north carolina april 16th new orleans
louisiana
april 17 dallas texas april 18th austin
texas god help us
april 21st the chicago theater the home
of lightfoot
the great friday april 22nd houston
texas saturday april 23rd cincinnati
ohio sunday april 24th northfield ohio
and um that is it and those are the
dates and then we're going to australia
by the way this is a big news we don't
have the tickets on sale yet but we're
going the last week of april
in the first week of may 2 australia
please it's going to be very very
exciting but
timberlandcomedy.com we have all the
links there for you guys to get uh
tickets for the uk annual shows and when
we put australia on
uh the line we will be um
we will have that for you as well so
we're very excited about all of that and
then we're wrapping up then we're gonna
spend spring to summer and really the
fall chilling out on the internet maybe
building some new material and then
we'll hit you guys later with more
material better
uh you know a live show we're gonna do
the live podcast a little bit this
summer a very small
mini tour of the live podcast this
summer tiny little tour five or seven
cities
probably in august and we're just gonna
be doing the podcast live we're gonna
plan those shows out uh samia and ben
can
uh come see you uh there
um as always we appreciate you listening
uh this is a great letter that should be
sent to vladimir putin immediately if we
have an interest in ending the war which
uh we don't we probably don't because
everybody likes war what is it good for
absolutely nothing that's what they say
um uh tim j dillon on instagram and
twitter please follow me
patreon.com
the tim dylan show if you want bonus
content we upload one patreon a week and
we are doing our higher tier the raw
child tier we're doing that episode this
week you guys will have it we apologize
for lateness the problem is of course
we've been on the road when the road
slows down which everything's a lot
easier um
we hope that uh everybody is doing well
we hope that you're not uh too affected
by the economic uh realities that are
emerging because of this ukraine uh
crisis uh it's affecting all of us
whether you're an oligarch
or a young
detransitioned child everybody needs the
gas
to get up and do what we do in this
country which is go through the
drive-thru at raising canes
good night